[Music]  Swedish Prime Minister Stefan Levin  comes to Brussels for a debate with  members on the future of Europe  Parliament wants to improve parents and  carers work-life balance including the  right to 10 days of paternity leave  flexible working conditions and two  months of paid parental leave Parliament  discusses boosting funding for the  European Social Fund plus members want  to devote more resources to youth  employability and helping young people  at risk of exclusion members debate an  overhaul of gas market rules which would  extend rules on internal EU gas  pipelines to pipelines coming from non  EU countries the EU wants to tackle  fraud in the road transport sector  including breaching of cabotage rules  and letterbox companies members will  also discuss a driver's rest periods and  posting of drivers  [Music]